qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors je t'envoie
quelqu'un n'avait certes eu droit qu'à
moi ya moyen de faire quelque chose j'ai
le morceau de dent ouais tu peux pas
vous voyez madame aime celle m il
m'arrive un drame une dent j'ai perdu
une dent ménard sur la tête de ma mère
voilà les 35 heures des bas et j'ai
perdu
j'admets que j'appelle le dentiste en
direct non mais sans déconner j'appelle
le christ en direct et on apprendra le
docteur ou pas qui est là on peut
appeler le docteur attendez on va
appeler docteur de bayonne auteur marc
andré
[Musique]
ma vie
les frères est ce que c'est possible
dans cette chaîne j'ai demandé un
docteur on dirait un serrurier le même
nom mais sur la tête de ma mère on
dirait qu'il va et on dirait qu'il va
exploser une forte
non mais a été laissé le seul docteur et
bien son truc sans manette en main n'a
comme ça avant tout est là bas derrière
et je crois qu à weight insisté tous
comprenez vous et moi docteur karin oui
vous aurez karine merci d'être karim
j'ai perdu en bourse dans ses thèmes
provisoire ouais bon toi tu peux rien
faire c'est pas d'anti non
malheureusement
et ben alors tu vas faire des études que
tu reviendras cette non mais comme enjeu
mais karim il faut que j'appelle le
dentiste sans déconner il faut que
j'appelle le d'anti jeu va payer tout de
suite karim comment tu me sens là bien
sa droite à quelque chose pour moi au
cas où ouais bah quoi c'est des cachets
des cachets
[Rires]
ouais ça te fait de l'apathie je te dis
que j'ai pas du tout confiance en toi
venez à la personne c'est ce docteur qui
va vous suivre c'est vous qui allez mais
non pas 35 heures n'ont mana est vrai
sinon c'est le médecin pas mourir un peu
pâlot mais karim tu as quoi là dedans
c'est pour mes notes il a un truc pour
se laver des malades ou non mais sans
rire par hectare et animateur est tous
là bah ouais parce que je fais à labatut
anesthésistes réanimateurs donc les
dents je sais pas ce que j'aurais fait
une croix tu voulais man est saisi pour
faire des 35 heures karim en tout cas
moi je t'aime bien
j'espère que j'aurai pas problème c'est
tout ce que j'espère mais je te sens tu
restes avec moi tu es là au cas où il ya
un truc tu interviens direct direct soir
car le shérif ce pôle est dans mon
ouvrage atlantis
pour les 35 heures je l'appelais tout de
suite j'ai appelé tout de suite quand
même un ami qui est dentiste non mais je
vous jure que c'est vrai non mais peut
mettre une provision à regarder j'ai
perdu une dent sans déconner on dirait
dirait requins dans le monde
non je peux pas sourire non vous fait
toujours comme mais oui ça va allô allô
voilà ça va pas je t'appelle je suis en
direct la commande à l'ajustement
haut-parleurs dit moi je suis dans la
merde parce que je suis à l'antenne là
pour les 35 heures j'ai perdu ma dent
may provisoire
non mais sans rire tu crois qu'à moyen
moyen de faire qui jaugent et le morceau
de dent ouais tu peux pas vous voyez là
même celle m suite c'est vrai tu nous
rappelles on est en direct attendait sur
le quai 10 octobre
on va avancer on va avancer
[Musique]